les gens qui travaillent pas lundi donc
le dimanche soir c'est la meilleure
soirée
je connais un petit peu jetteraient des
baguettes gyrophare tout ça on
n'entendait rien on a continué jusqu'à
la boîte du coup ils sont sortis nous
ont arrêtés à l'entrée de la boîte et on
leur a dit bac en fait tout allait bien
on était juste heureuse de sortir en
fait on criait tellement fort que les
gens s'inquiétaient et se demander baba
ce qui nous arrivait et au final c'était
là la fin du service
ils sont partis se changer et sont venus
on les a gentiment attendue non avare
d'amendé pour tapage nocturne et ils
nous ont dit pas si vous nous attendent
et on rentre on vote avec vous nous
qu'on les a attendus en iran droite avec
eux
bravo belle histoire belle histoire un
quart est merveilleux c'est vrai il
emboîte totem bien danseurs rarement un
cependant je suis un boucher un bon
danseur ça va je me débrouille
toulousain bat l avec toi allez vas-y
aller batailler cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]